Hey Thoughty2 here.
At some point in your life you may have become
frustrated with modern day life.
The awful music, long work hours, you complain
that everyone’s living through social media,
rather than actually living.
You may even foolishly believe that life in
the past was superior and that you were born
at the wrong time.
You may think that life was simpler back then,
less hectic and stressful perhaps.
But in reality how good or bad was pre-industrial
life?
Before machinery and modern medicine.
If we go back to the middle-ages or even all
the way back to the Roman empire, was life
ever any better than it is now?
Let’s take a dirty detour and flirt with
the filthy past to discover what it was really
like to live in the time of the history books.
So, why a dirty detour into the past?
Because ladies and gents, the past was disgusting,
utterly, down-right filthy.
Cities were also disease ridden.
The bigger the city, the filthier it was.
Human’s are pretty disgusting like that.
The biggest contributor to this problem was
obviously the sewers, or lack of.
Until the last 200 years most cities around
the world relied on a sewerage system no more
advanced than throwing your waste out your
window and hoping it doesn’t land on your
wife’s head.
Some fancier cities though, like ancient Rome
and London had open sewers, how opulent.
To put it crudely, open sewers were no more
than a river of shit running past your front
door.
Very few people had clean running water in
the past, only the wealthy, who’s water
was delivered through lead pipes which gave
them heavy metal poisoning.
Wait a minute, back up, weren’t the Romans
credited with creating vast underground sewerage
systems?
Well yes, but they only built those in the
dwellings of the upper-class.
They also built some public toilets that lead
to underground sewers.
Despite them having sewers we know from the
history books that the majority of the lower
class in ancient Rome and elsewhere, still
chose to chuck their waste onto the street,
it’s just easier I guess.
And in smaller towns and villages across the
world, all throughout history, dumping your
waste onto the street, or all over your neighbour’s
cabbages, has been the standard way to dispose
of it.
Interestingly, emptying waste out of your
window was actually illegal in medieval London,
that didn’t stop most people from doing
it though.
The recommended method of waste disposal in
London was actually to dump it in the river
Thames, which is where thousands of people
also got their drinking water from, nice.
So what happened to the endless waste piling
up on the street?
Well, sewage collectors, known as “muck
rakers” would roam the streets and collect
all the waste then take it to local farmers
to sell as fertiliser.
So next time you complain about your job,
just remember, you could be playing Pokemon
Go with human feces for a living.
That’s if you were lucky enough to have
a local shite shoveller.
Some historic accounts tell of streets that
were caked in solidified waste so deep, that
stepping stones had to be built to traverse
them.
But that would only have been a minor inconvenience
for your medieval self, you would have been
far too busy trying to stay alive to care
about the filth.
Death and disease was everywhere and almost
every disease out there was hideous and meant
certain death, or if you were lucky an amputated
limb, without anesthesia of course.
Diseases such as leprosy, diabetes, dysentery
and measles were rife and there were no cures
or treatments, like we have today.
In fact, before modern medicine if you managed
to reach the age of 40 and your face hadn’t
fallen off yet, then you were incredibly lucky.
But it wasn’t all bad, contrary to popular
belief, peasants in the middle ages did eat
rather well.
They weren’t starved like books and films
would have us believe.
The poor actually ate a plentiful diet of
porridge, bread, meats, cheeses, fruits and
plenty of beer to wash it all down.
There was also significantly less violence
outside of war than the movies portray.
Medieval taverns were relatively civilized,
until of course you go and steal somebody
else’s whore and you get garroted.
So next time you complain about modern-day
life and your long work hours at least you’re
not a slave to some lord or emperor, doing
back-breaking work seven days a week, all
the while trying to avoid the plague, and
the myriad of other fatal diseases.
And when you walk home at night, the ground
you trod upon is probably nicely paved and
relatively clean, so just be thankful, because
your street could be covered in the collective
works of your neighbour’s bowels.
And on that cheery note, thanks for watching.